un administré qui reçoit une demande de
la mairie de justifier de son
attachement à la commune où il est censé
voter
la procédure est relativement banal
iliad mon plaisir est ont administré
comme les autres mais aussi un candidat
déclaré à la mairie de saint joseph
lorsqu'il reçoit fin octobre ce courrier
signé du premier adjoint au maire simon
morin lui aussi candidat
pour lui la manoeuvre politique ne fait
aucun doute que j'avais été prévenu par
le maire tanon athanase jeanne rose qui
m'avait dit fais attention je crois que
simon morin c'est rayé de la liste
électorale de manière très précise
il a adressé cet axe est ce courrier à
gondo saint joseph
il se trouve que j'ai déménagé que je
loue maintenant de l'autre côté de la
rue effectivement bon dos j'ai donc
appelé la poste et la dame de la post
m'a dit effectivement monsieur mon
plaisir on sait pas où vous déposez le
courrier je lui ai indiqué l'adresse
précise et puis surtout j'ai transmis à
monsieur mauresque plus important le
document qui atteste que je suis en
droit de me présenter à saint-joseph
puisque j'ai payé la taxe d'habitation
de l'année qui précède année d'élection
il ya de montplaisir précise par
ailleurs avoir été conseiller général du
canton et votées depuis près de 40 ans à
saint joseph
pour simon morin ces accusations n'ont
pas lieu d'être
il s'agit d'une simple procédure
administrative d'ailleurs prévue par le
code électoral il faut pas non plus
parce qu'il est candidat
qu'on laisse à penser que c'est parce
qu'il est candidat que la mairie
entreprend toutes ces investigations
c'est normal et naturel c'est ce qu'on
fait pour tout le monde depuis un
certain moment document adressé à
monsieur montplaisir reviennent en
mairie avec la notion n'habite pas à
cette adresse la première réponse de
monsieur vos plaisirs
il a opté pour la fiscalité c'est à dire
à opter sur le fait qu'ils s'acquittent
donné peau je vous ai dit à partir de ce
moment si le document qui nous envoie ne
justifie pas n'est pas suffisamment
probants pour faire pour dire qu'il est
qu'ils s'acquittent donné peau en lui
envoie un courrier pour qu'ils puissent
expliquer et une fois que j'explique si
l'idée lévesque s'est terminé 1 si les
pas d'un des règles à l'approché du
gauteng
pour l'instant la radiation de yan
monplaisir de la liste électorale n'est
qu'une
éventualité la campagne électorale à
saint-joseph promet d'être animée avec
pas moins de neuf prétendants déclarés
au fauteuil de maire